nothing says mother's day like venom
killing spider-man i'm sure aunt may
would love this
get ready get hit with that venom crack
i was gonna say raccoon
john just constantly can't i i love this
why are you always interrupting me it's
my face why are you always interrupting
it's why are you always
yeah we're gonna watch this video let's
do it
eddie stop this madness you are better
than this
multiverse
all the right kind of things for a
youtube video
something tells me this is going to be a
lot of lines of what i want
[Applause]
[Music]
nice that's my boy
really made him look greasy too
kitty stop this madness you are better
than this
let the symbiote go
[Music]
parker
[Music]
sorry about that
[Music]
come on eddie bring it on so many snacks
and so little time
what the hell peter you barely put up a
fight
we are hungry
that's cool
well done something tells me uh
this is tom hardy's suggestion
yeah this is what he was hoping for
those photos that tom hardy kept putting
uh up on instagram he meant for those to
be specific dms to mighty raccoon and
just accidentally kept posting
tom hardy is mighty raccoon
this is his hobby on the side
well i love the tone of it and i love
the mood of it the the overall look i
thought was great
and like the venom design just felt
really
nasty slimy i love that and whoever
voiced
venom as well as peter parker i thought
did a really great job i want to see
that side of venom that just loves to
munch on people
and just absorb it you highlight eat up
oh
so cool yeah the animation's really
great i do wish peter parker spider-man
put up a little bit more of a fight
though
yeah even though it's in the title the
whole point is to get to venom
killing spider-man i wish there's a
little bit more of a build up to it
that being said it's still a really cool
video still super slick i would like to
see an expanded upon version of this
oh yeah dude i mean this was like ripped
right out of that street scene from the
first venom movie so in that way like
i actually got pretty immersed into it
and yeah i mean i would have liked
to see spider-man kick a little bit more
ass but i thought it was really awesome
how they addressed the whole like
venom spider logo thing yeah i thought
it was cool
when he eats him that the spider logo
starts appearing on his back this is
like
a new origin of sorts yeah
yeah cause that's clearly supposed to be
tom holland spider-man there's nothing
really here that specifically states
or showcases supposed to be specifically
tom hardy's venom other than the fact
that he didn't have the spider-man logo
there are theories that have been going
around on the internet of how possibly
tom hardy's venom could uh get like the
actual
original venom design with the spider
symbol i mean i don't think sony would
go down this path
of killing spider-man and then again the
symbol but in terms of like a fan
fiction idea which is something that
mighty raccoon primarily does is like
great fan fiction
i like that concept i think it's really
cool and plus maybe they're just other
spider-mans from spider verses of the
spoon
a sponge what's it called
pictures universal marvel characters
rolls off the tongue one of those will
come in or whatever
either way i mean yeah other than just
wanting a little bit more of a build up
i still really enjoy this video a lot
i think we should just do one with every
spider-man up until this point and then
maybe culminate with like
every version of spider-man tries to
take venom and then you know we watch
venom morph
into like you know in this one he takes
on the logo so maybe each spider-man he
kills he takes on a piece of
get a spider pig snout maybe like a
spider noir hat
i love this some kind of i love venom
mech suit
i love this i should be mitered and also
i thought the music was really cool too
i love the sinister tones to it man that
was great all right guys for mighty
raccoon if you haven't subscribed to the
guys channel yet
do so as soon as you can and also if you
haven't seen our heroes united reaction
i love the hell out of that video
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification
notoriety button and last but not least
scuba steve and erica tuesday two of our
patrons who are artists in their own
right
erica working artist animation go follow
her facebook page scuba steve
graffiti artist go follow his instagram
page i thought it'd be fun if
one day these two met each other erica
lives in burbank scuba steven rhode
island
how would this happen watch
i'll be playing scuba i'll be playing
erica exterior sidewalk
afternoon rhode island steve aka scuba
steve spray paints graffiti's a wall
erika aka erica tuesday walks by smoking
some herb
from her pen yo dude that's illegal you
know scuba turns around as it clearly
attracted her
uh are you gonna call the cops
no it actually looks pretty rad sandwich
oh
do you like sandwiches because uh i
could eat you up
don't you mean eat me out
are you are you flirting with me maybe
your art's cool i'm an artist myself
really
what do you do i've worked on some
animation shows i get paid to draw
oh so you're legit unlike you uh
so you from rhode island no i'm from
burbank california what are you doing
out here
got really high and somehow ended up
here a little adventure
you know how it is man i like adventures
just the other day
i re-watched a quiet place you know you
like horror movies
yeah critters critters 2 critters 3
critters 4
and 29 teens critters attack wow you
really like critics
yeah i'm a critter of the wood why do
you like critters so much i don't know
greg's on my facebook page that the word
critters mentioned a lot
what horror do you like i grew up on the
classics freddy jason
chucky i gotta say you're really hot
hey thanks man that means a lot uh
you're welcome you got that rhode island
italian confidence
yeah i got some italian in my blood do
you
that explained how hot you are i don't
know greg couldn't find out on my
facebook page
would you like a little italian in you
are you saying you have a little italian
sausage
no i'm saying that i uh relax i'm
kidding if you're ever in burbank you
should come chill in my hot tub with me
did uh did craig find that out on your
facebook page too
no he's he's been in it i really hit my
pulses
no he's he's actually been in it oh
don't worry
i never saw his massive italian sausage
oh
you really could be a model i love to
photograph you sometime that's one of my
other passions
why don't you spray paint us doing it on
the wall scuba steve becomes too aroused
and instantly explodes
erika takes a hit on her herb hops under
her space cruiser and dries off
and that's how they mess true story
my nuts hurt
you